what's up man how you been bro
everything's 30 everything's 30 man you
throw me pointing out music man just
keep going staying focused staying in
the high you know what I mean you know
now
you uh had obviously man uh when pnb
passed away that hit you hard it hit me
hard man he used to record here it's
been on my show many times
um and I felt like for a while there
like you kind of might have been done
with Music Man yep
um yeah I wanna uh
want to pay me man I have one I'm losing
like three friends in a month and all
that should be cut and um where are they
just like you know I mean hit me yeah
right after the session I was just
recording you know what I mean on our
journey you know what I'm saying yeah
and then my boy I just called him like
yo bro I love you uh uh you know what
I'm saying he was just like worried man
we need more love
um
you fool me we just lost tape yeah and
um it just was it's just bad man it was
bad to hear that [ __ ] for me yeah so I
wound up you know what I mean just
before me slam it all out you told me I
had nobody there to talk to at that
moment right so I just let it all out
you know what I mean um just rebirth
myself you know what I'm saying or how
wait I was about to say how do you feel
mentally now like are you it feels like
you're back you got your head back in
the game on the rap [ __ ] I appreciate it
yeah heck yeah it feels amazing word man
I feel like that was um you know take
pnb my boy you know what I mean a lot
ticket passed away in the hood I'm just
they just you know I mean lose it to
Industry friends you know I mean just
really just then it gave me like oh
sprouted just keep going bro like don't
give up you know what I'm saying like I
feel like none of them would want me to
ever give up before I'm saying or what I
put my you know my spits that the stone
to do you know what I mean what I really
wanted to do in this keep focus on what
we doing
touching the people and giving them the
energy spreading the messages the
knowledge and just love if I'm saying
keep going for me yeah that's funny